今日は母散らす d カップです
今日はいい
言語
学習者の毒1宣言というテーマについて
あのお話ししたいと思います
沢山のその外国語を勉強した中でいつも感じたことはやはり
学習者勉強する人が独立しないと
いけません
指導権を取らないといけません
で今朝それを考えて
一つのまあ独立宣言をこしらえました
英語でですよだから今はそれよ
あの
皆さんにそれ言います8乗個入ってんがあります
まずソリオ英語で読んでそれから日本語であの読めます
お願いします
じゃじゃあまずは1オール ai キャロライン無地ノー t got me for
me to serve you
言葉を勉強できるのは僕だけです私が自分で勉強しないといけません
第三者が僕のためにそれじゃあそれを勉強できるかっていうを上げにはいきません
全部僕に頼ります依存して
独立してますから
第2位
ios あいまいオンラリーゲッティビーズ follow in my んです
その勉強活動それは自分で決めます
僕の興味によって自分の
その
勉強活動決めます徳利した形で
第3
it ですあいまいオーロラボールのライム二枚 onaga シーン is r
相棒のブライアンテスツ
この勉強している言葉で僕のレベルは何かっていうのは
自分の評価が大事私がそれを評価します
提出によってそれを決めるわけにはいきません
第4
i read and listen to do 長いウェディ
ion
黒子その聞く内容
読む内容それが
私が興味を感じるものに限ります
第三者がそれを決める立場じゃないですか
私が決めます
第5
irena ファッション r プロフェッション
バーウェルイーリー this true
スマイルライブというメスアディスター even なぁレスター
へパーキッド in ios free アルスター
僕は選んだ
内容を聞いた内容に対してそれじゃ理解道
その示す表明するための
そういう還付変人暮らす家質問ですねじゃあ理解しましたかそういう質問は一切やるの
脅威します
やりません
その読んだ内容を聞いたなよええ
あまり送りができないあるいは間違って理解できる
するのはですねそれをこの権利です
和田日が独立している新しい言葉を勉強している人にとってはですね
の立場としてソリオ毛利がしないことを一つの権利です
続けて読めば続けて聴いたら
読んだらですね
最終的にはわかりますから
独立したただしで続ければ
せっ inoreader パーシー the voodoo me well
impo s bar トゥノウウィンティー中前キャッシュドバイのだからー
単語枚ない単語
およびあの
分母に関する質問
そういうものに対してですね僕が今日目がある
広告費があるときに平部ます
ならいます
先生が今はあなたが9割を勉強すべきだ
行くとじゃなくて私が主導権を取って興味のある時に好奇心があるときに
素振りを調べたり勉強します
サーバに web アイスティあご4 q 3コミュニケーションの at
section
で
第4学校の新しい言葉で話しするときに目標は
者のコミュニケーションなんですよね
完璧に話しするのは目標じゃないんです
コミュニケーションです
は一番最後
ファイルわぁウィーズリー
imogen this fun p ポラ運命
4枚 p くれるアーマーチームず bebo ios to be クリーンカー
with 愛撫じゃあスウェイ
もし私が今のその上空に基づいてですねそういうことをすれば
その周りの人から独立
できるんですよ
周りの人が僕をまあ批判するか評価するかあるいは彼らを
がその僕はあの日本するだろうかと僕自身内装上るそうれたりとかそういうような
すべてから独立できます
それよりも自分の自分に対する批判的なそういう大道
から独立します
若菜さんに勉強できますそれは今日は
[音楽]
あの件国が救助 no
独立宣言したご意見
ぜひあどういういかがいて教えてください者なら